recording in progress
we interact with our world in
a digital domain much more than we ever
have in the past
especially recording in progress
where many of the transactions or
interactions that we had with
people in face-to-face mode had to shift
over to the online mode so
um it's not just of course online
systems that require design of
useful useful and suitable user
interfaces and user experiences almost
any product service or system does but
um
the the
way that you interact with the product
can determine whether it's a successful
product or a failure can you comment a
bit on that issue about the role of UI
and ux design in today's world
sure yeah so I think uh any business
needs nowadays ux and UI because
everything is technology driven and if
it everything is technology driven you
need to get systems where people can
interact with them in a natural way and
to do that we need to invest a lot of
our time now doing user interfaces and
creating user experiences for the people
so
uh as the customers you know because the
demand of technology is increasing and
as the competition in the market is
increasing so we need to basically
create these systems which are easy to
use
uh
uh also in uh easy to interact with and
enjoyable to use that's not uh creating
something to use it but also making a
system pleasurable and enjoyable to use
so that's what the ux industry really
helps in
and the contrast is as we've all had the
experience of
a system or user interface that wasn't
intuitive wasn't easy to use required us
to take extra steps or even would take
us down dead end paths in the user
interface so that you'd reach a point
where
never get back to what you needed to do
or never accomplish your goal so
um of course in past years the classic
example of that was the voicemail system
that would never take you to the person
you needed to talk to and
the that's a an example of a very poor
interface and accuser experience
um and that we we too often replicate
that
online or
physical product worlds
um and that can cause
a company to fail not just a product but
this is why the this course and
expertise of people have issued will
help you avoid that horrible fate and
instead get to a much better goal of
something that people are delighted with
something that people want to tell their
friends to buy so
what do you do as a UI ux designer so
there's a whole series can you describe
this flow where is The View so yeah so
uh as a ux designer it's basically
umbrella and you do a lot of different
activities under ux the first main uh
function for the ux person we have is
the strategy building a strategy built
on target use across so you focus on
people uh as a Target you know for whom
you need to design
it would think from a perspective of who
will be the your users
and to understand that we conduct
interviews to understand the user we try
to really know from them what they need
and then build a custom experience
for them so uh first knowing from their
end what is needed and then we try to
solve those problems and find a solution
for it and during that process we might
create uh flow charts we might get
storyboards you might get user flows you
might create task flows through that
and the ux is always research driven so
you do a lot of research and testing on
the user Behavior how users behave and
during that process also talk about uh
different uh topics like information
architecture doing user research
prototyping wire framing
and a lot of other things which comes
around that uh job as a great designer
and we try to maintain the Competitive
Edge so that's the main thing so uh you
might have similar app for
the similar services so how to stand out
on the market
and that's our motive to do it as a ux
and UI designer
and to finally get the business
and and so understanding how the product
fits into that flow and that environment
it ties everything together so that you
end up with a product that satisfies
the the goals that you identified from
your your target users
and uh and delights those
but we talk about here's a sample job
description it's a lot of text to read
but I'm just going to kind of go over it
um
this
this is a sample from
indeed.com for the job listing and this
is what they're asking people to do you
work with your design team and
development teams to produce engaging
intuitive enjoyable user experiences for
end users
ux designer do you participate in
product Discovery design and delivery
you work closely with the client to
understand the business needs with end
users to understand their goals working
with a product owner develop a product
division you craft the product Solutions
present those to the design team
development team end users and
stakeholders to collect feedback and
iterate toward the best solution that's
the research phase and you establish
patterns and create familiar experiences
that reduce the end user's cognitive
load
so you become more intuitive experience
you directly impact the lives of your
team client and most definitely the
answers so that's described pretty much
all of the steps that the issue
discussed
um the requirements for someone in this
field they need to have some experience
doing
research and data to guide user
experience recommendations they have to
have experience with prototyping
presenting design Solutions human
centered design tools like figma and
sketch
familiarity with front-end Technologies
with the web and then a portfolio
with your design Solutions
so it's an interesting job description
and what you hopefully you'll see is
that
um
you'll be able to satisfy a job
description like that from the
experience of this program it opens up
many skills that one was ux designer ux
researcher was the subset of that which
involves testing those designs against
user experiences uh user feedback
and
the iterative part of feeding back into
that design Loop the UI designer
developer combining those into the ux UI
developer job is sometimes done
then people who are in the web design or
front-end web design development
um
also
benefit from having understanding of the
the UI and ux so all of these types of
career paths are ways in through
the UI and ux skills and then they open
up all the other
career paths that you can move up from
so
I have a poll question for the audience
in this question if you're on the
streaming service you can put ABCD into
your comments
but um
this poll asks
what has prevented you from
taking up a course in uon ux design up
till now is it because you couldn't find
a program
that had that kind of comprehensive
curriculum for all those different
skills is is it because you don't feel
that you would end up with a practical
experience in your portfolio
you find it difficult to learn through
self-paced pre-recorded videos or is it
because your work schedule is uh
too tight to let you have enough time
for learning
we'll leave this open for a few more
minutes having a few more seconds I
don't want to leave it open for half an
hour
um
and the numbers have stopped changing so
uh oh they're coming in again please get
your answers in the next 10 seconds
we'll then close the poll
close it in five
and here we go
so sharing the result
biggest concern people have is not
getting the Practical experience that
they can demonstrate in the portfolio
and the next biggest is not finding a
program that has comprehensive
curriculum that covers everything that
vishua talked about
let's move ahead
discuss
the program from the University of
Massachusetts Amherst the UI ux boot
camp
it's a five month long program
it is completely delivered online
and we'll go over the curriculum shortly
but we'll demonstrate to you that it in
fact covers all of the skills that vishu
talked about and that were covered in
that
job description
it includes the ability on the same
platform to do your case studies your
projects all of your implementation
within a Sandbox environment virtual
machine that is provided to you so you
can do everything from your desktop or
your laptop and even much of the
material that you can review on your
mobile device so you can access this
platform 24x7
and do much of your work on your
schedule whenever you have the available
time
uh the only part that
needs a hard schedule that you have to
adhere to is
the class the live virtual classes that
happen generally on a weekly basis
do you have to attend those and you do
have to make a commitment for this
program for around 10 to 15 hours a week
of effort
um but this is uh not the same as a
traditional boot camp environment where
you get locked in a room for three weeks
and um
hopefully come out of it remembering
some of what you learned this is a much
more Interactive
and a much easier paced program so that
you can again fit it into your schedule
the way that uh fits your lifestyle
it gives you the online live virtual
interaction with your instructors so
that you can
ask them questions live you can follow
along with their exercises you can
interact with your peers in the
classroom and then you have other
support platforms
that allow you to interact with the
other classmates and the instructors
outside of classroom members so
this is a comprehensive program
it fits into your schedule and it lets
you complete this process in five months
the end of the process you get a
certificate issued by the University of
Amherst along with simply learn
that certifies that you have completed
the core courses and
demonstrated the skill set just acquired
through Hands-On learning new projects
based on industry type requirements
including a Capstone which we'll discuss
in a few moments
um but the instructions delivered by top
trainers one of whom is a Microsoft ux
designer she comes in from one of the
classes
and at the end of the program you have
an additional period of career
assistance
that's available to you for six months
after you earn your certificate to help
you with your job search
why the University of Amherst uh
Eisenberg School University of Amherst
is a 130 year old University and it's
School of Management was founded in
1947.
so it works
75 years about and the
it's one of the top ranked
U.S universities that ranks in the top
25 public universities in the United
States on the program uh say the boot
camp program gives you uh UMass Amherst
certificate
master classes along the way uh Alumni
Association membership and you receive
three credits transferable to an
Eisenberg online MBA program
so
um having the UMass Amherst on your CV
is a prestigious accomplishment
people will recognize the name of the
University
our eligibility and prerequisites
are very straightforward you only need
to be 18 years of age or older with a
high school diploma or equivalent
so this is not a postgraduate program
despite what I said on the previous
slide this is a a boot camp program Open
pretty much to everyone you do not have
to have a minimum of a new work
experience although we always recommend
that it's best to have some work
experience when you come into the
program
be familiar with how
skills of UI and ux fit into
flow of a organization
this is really doesn't intended for
people who are entering into the design
field and also current designers who
want to upskill and
learn
the newer techniques
a broader range of techniques for their
work
so
with that I'm going to go to the next
question which is how much work
experience do you currently have
just to get a feel for who's in our
audience
launch the poll
they're currently in school or are you
in the workforce and how long
and this is not restricted to work in
the UI ux design field but any any work
experience
this open
for another three seconds two one
all right and
about 40 percent of our audience are
folks who are still studying again if
you've got a that I'm presuming that
means you are in University and
therefore you have your high school
diploma
um and people in the workforce uh we're
actually our audience today tens
to people with a bit more experience
past the five-year mark
so
let's move on
and we'll talk about how the program
prepares you so if you and I will talk
about how
the program works and
then he will show how the learning
management system operates
so visha if you could discuss the
curriculum that this program covers so
appreciate that yeah so uh this this
curriculum basically starts uh from a
very basic level I would say even if we
don't have any experience with working
in the ux and UI industry this course
will be a fit for you because even you
have experience that's good to have but
if you don't have any experience we
start from the very basic foundations so
we start with the orientation session
where you come to know uh how to attend
the classes and how to access your LMS
and getting a little bit overview with
the with the instructors and then we uh
start with the user experience design we
try to know the basic principles uh
which are there in the user experience
design and what are the different
processes or a methodologies you can you
can follow during the user experience
design uh steps or process you can say
as a job role
then we talk about the user interface
design
the UI designing which is what the
customers or the end users would see and
other design principles behind it
and then talking about the UI
prototyping and styling so the UI
prototyping and styling talks about that
how can you create a prototype of a
workable design
which will be the end result and we get
the prototype in the ux process or in
the UI process because
we want to test
as early as possible so we can know uh
whether the design is working whether we
are going in the right direction or not
so we do a lot of UI prototyping
doing the whole uh ux design phase
and with that UI prototyping we also do
some styling when getting the hive ready
mockups and all this comes from a ux SL
like we have already talked about it
before that you do a lot of ux research
you try to test with the users to try to
know what are the current problems of
the users and if whether our prototyping
whether our UI prototype is resolving
those issues or not
and for that we do the user testing and
at the end you're going to have a
Capstone project which
would be a project to give you the real
life experience of a ux project and a UI
project plus it adds to your portfolio
so by the end of the course you would
have something to present to you to the
to the recruiters or to your clients if
you want to work as a freelancer so you
want to have real world experience with
the Capstone projects
in this course
and um as you can see out there's
electives that are available these are
at no additional cost they depend only
on your
um interest and your investment of time
so if you want to take them you're
perfectly welcome to they are not
required to earn your certificate they
give you experience in building a
website from the ground up and also in
the design thinking
um
discipline that applies to UI ux but
also much other
much of the other work that people do in
the digital world today
so we talked you saw in the job
description and it mentioned Sigma and
sketch and
you look tell us a little bit about
these tools uh just uh
a couple words about each one so
yeah so figma I think I would say the
figma is the industry leading software
when it comes to UI designing and doing
a bit of presentations on the ux so
figma is a is a tool which is free to
use and almost
any any corporate company or if you go
to any MNC they're probably using figma
for sure so it's a kind of an essential
tool to have it if you talk about
blacksmic uh blasmic is basically a wire
framing tool if you want to do quick
wire framing for any screen you can use
blasphemic for that I personally love
last spring for wireframing
then we have Envision Invision is what's
similar to figma and it also offers you
a option to manage bigger projects so if
you're a team of let's say 100 200 300
people and you want to create a design
system and efficiently manage it that's
where you can use envision and sketch
have been a app of the Year by Apple as
well it's it's a love tool by UI
designers
people who use Mac but it only works on
Mac and there are many more softwares in
this industry you have as tools we have
uh Marvel we have Pro dot IO there a lot
of many tools we have uh we we work as a
ux designer but I think uh even if you
learn if you just Master two or three
tools that should be sufficient to
basically uh get you going in the UI
industry
and one of the great things about the
program is that you aren't just exposed
to the tools but you're required to use
them in your projects and
at the end of the process when you claim
that you have experience using figma or
balsamic
you can demonstrate that
and all that ties together in the
Capstone project which happens at the
end of this process
and ties together all of the different
skills that you've learned in each of
the courses leading up to the
um the Capstone project can take three
or four weeks done under the mentorship
of an instructor somebody likely issue
who will meet with you weekly and make
sure that you aren't going down any dead
ends or rabbit holes
um that you're staying on track to solve
the problem that you've chosen you get
to select the a problem for the Capstone
project that you want to uh
solve it is based on an industry
requirement pick a industry domain like
Commerce and that type of thing and then
you solve the challenge by building
user experience
and user interface
that matches that challenge
again it's a three to four week project
it becomes essentially your final exam
for the entire program
it's assessed graded and if it's
successful
uh it shows that you have
mastered the whole skills so each of the
certificates or or Milestones that you
achieve along the way in the courses
then are confirmed
with the success of the Capstone project
so at this point I'm going to ask the
issue if he'll share his screen and show
what the learning environment actually
looks like
sure
so I'll just be taking you through the
uh LMS uh and showing you how does the
elements and how do you access your
course
so we are going to the LMS uh dot simple
design.com as you can see here
and once you enter your elements once
you login into LMS as well now you will
see all your programs you are enrolled
in and probably once you enroll for the
ux and UI course it comes on the master
programs and uh if I scroll down as you
can see I have the UI in the ux expert
course over here so let's go to one of
the programs if you go to the program
uh when we access the program you have
uh three options one is the course
itself and it shows you how the course
is divided into multiple modules
and
it gives you the topic for the each
module over here
and as you complete the module you will
get certified in that particular module
uh given
then we also have the electives here so
electives is kind of optional and if you
like to take elective for your
self-development and you know learning
some uh HTML css3 JavaScript essential
uh part for the development in the front
end so you can basically learn through
the electives as well
not composite but uh you can do
Financial knowledge and then you have
certification so it shows you what
certifications you have gained so far as
per the each model and then of course
you will have the master certificate at
the end as well uh which will be uh
unlocked for you and you will have a
certification for your electives as well
as you can see here
besides this
certification can look a little
different depending on the program
you're enrolled in and if you go back to
the courses in the courses itself if we
enter a particular course let's say I'm
going to the course over here we'll say
resume learning I'm not really updating
it here
and once you enter into the course you
have the sales learning products in case
this Alpha negative product is not
available like for example it says this
particular topic is covered in the live
virtual classroom that means it will be
covered with the instructor so uh most
of the modules
in the in the learning track for the ux
and UI program are covered by the live
instructors as you can see here and you
can enter your live classes basically
you can see your live classes over here
and once you complete the learning you
will have a certificate over here
unlocked for you
and if you go back
you will also have an option whatever
the instructor shares you with you
during the course you will have those
ppts access of those ppts in a soft
format to be downloaded from here so you
can access them as well besides this
in the learning management system you
can take notes for your additional
notes you can basically create notes
within the LMS and you can access the
community that's I think the biggest
advantage of you know having this access
to the LMS uh into the community you can
basically talk to your POS you can uh
you know interact with the over the
instructors and ask your queries in the
forums so as you can see I can basically
start a thread here and I can basically
connect like a forum with uh with my PL
or loss uh with uh those are
part of this course basically
so it's a big community of people
whom you can interact with and
get your plugins resolved as well if you
go back to the LMS
I'll just go back here
and all your courses will be uh
included over here you will also get
your recordings over here so if you have
any live classes maybe you missed it out
or you want to go through it again you
can access the recordings of these
sessions as well over here and the
industry experts will guide you
throughout the course
a little course is complete and you
always have the option to contact the
support at the simple learn if you find
if you have any issues with the LMS at
any point of time
right
thank you for that overview that's
perfect
yeah so as you can see from that you're
in the environment the whole time you
don't have to switch between systems
um when you do your projects you have a
virtual machine that's part of that
environment so you're not having to um
juggle a lot of different tools and
that's part of our UI and ux Design
um so let me
go back to the presentation
we've covered the learning environment
um I want to mention that the program
is under the direction of John Wells who
is the senior Vice Provost at University
of Massachusetts to Amherst and
um he supervises the curriculum he
supervises the delivery we are the
delivery partner for them so we provide
the Learning Management platform and
um
give them the tools to be able to have
their instructors
participate
um the instruction from this program is
through industry experts
um
and then here's an example of one of
them she teaches one of the classes or
we should turn it on who is working as a
senior ux designer at Microsoft
so you're going to hear from
people like vishu people like arishi who
are working in the field and can tell
you
practical ways to use the skills rather
than just a theory
we talk about learner outcomes
and
to facilitate the outcome that you want
to get from a program like this
we assume that
number of you are looking for a new
career
want to get into
um
UI ux design field or move up in your
career path within the field so we
provide a career assist Service as part
of this program again for six months
after you earn your certificate you have
access to these services
um of course include some expert
webinars and career events that simply
learn runs and are available to you for
free
lifelong learning
um however we also include
the different projects that become part
of your portfolio as part of the program
so that's something you take with you
lifelong and can demonstrate to show off
your level of skill and expertise
and then the job assist Services
themselves come through a company called
Talent Inc our partner so we give you
access to their job portal which has
exclusive job listings
a valuable part of the service certainly
I personally think that the other two
parts are even more valuable one is
resume review and rewrite the reason
that's so valuable is that today uh
unlike many years past
your resume is evaluated first by an AI
filter AI bot that will
compare your resume to the job
description
set up by the company
automated tracking system only the
resumes that match that filter are going
to get through to human beings so
the first step that your resume has to
fulfill is
matching up with the AI bot
be accessible to it so that it can
easily determine yes this person has the
correct
qualifications that match the job
description
the second thing the resume has to do is
you still have to fulfill the
traditional role of appealing to a human
being once it lands on their desk or
their screen
so the ability to meet both of these
requirements is kind of an art form
one of the great things about the resume
a rewrite Services it helps you
craft a resume that meets both of those
objectives then the one-on-one interview
service also has a two-part aspect to it
one is that you have to do interviews if
your resume gets in front of a human
being who says let's call this person in
that first level of interviews which may
be by phone maybe by Zoom maybe in
person will
focus on your technical qualifications
for the job description
you need to be able to present your
skills and explain what your experience
is and how this program has helped you
build up this portfolio
and
even you ability to use the tools so
that you can
make the argument that you meet the job
description of the type that the example
we showed earlier
then you have another set of interviews
which have to do with Team fit with
cultural fit with the organization
demonstrating that your type of person
that can work well with your manager and
your team so that level of interview
also has to be
very sharp
and the one-on-one interview prep
service will also deal with that type of
interview so you'll be prepared to do
both kinds of interviews
and shine in both
those
until you get the job
this is not a job guarantee program this
is a job search assistance program so
you need to decide which of these
Services you want to Avail yourself of
and what extent again these are
available to you for the six months
after you earn your certificate
and
to the extent that you want to use them
and support your job search they're
available to you
we also have as I mentioned webinars
which go on on an ongoing basis
simply learn conducts these
every week
with
topics about industry looking at
specific skills occasionally doing a
short course of one hour lesson
particular skill
talking about job career skills
career development techniques and even
things like how to search a job board
and get the best results
this is again free it's available to you
lifelong
and
of course your portfolio these are some
of the projects from this program that
will that you can choose to do in order
to um
do your Capstone and fulfill your fill
up your portfolio excuse me with um
with your experience so
with all of that together and with what
visha and I have shared with you today
uh is this a program that you're
interested in enrolling in
that question real quick
give this open for about 30 seconds but
it's a yes or no so it should be
straightforward
and
the numbers have stopped changing I'm
going to leave it open for five seconds
for you to get the lasting answers in
okay
and here's a result
more than 90 percent of people
responding said they're interested in
the program so let's share with you how
to do that
enrollment is very straightforward you
um
email us at ask us at simplylearn.net
what I will do right now is I'll put
that information
email address
into the chat
along with a link to the program page on
our website
and
let me
share that with you in the chat
all right there it is
uh you email us and ask us at
simplylearn.net
the review your application again
prerequisites are very straightforward
um
but mainly this is going to focus on
your level of Interest
in the field of UI ux design
we are asking people to make a financial
commitment
and the commitment of time over the next
five months
and so we want to make sure that people
are setting themselves up for success
not doing this in the I'm kind of a
unserious manner we want to make sure
that people who commit to this
fully commit and to have the best chance
of success
you'll receive an admission offer from
us
excuse me
your next cohort starts January 25th
with the orientation and the classes
themselves begin February 25th
the cost of this program is eight
thousand dollars U.S
which you can Finance over time at 704
dollars a month that's zero cost
financing
and
uh if you are doing this for your
current employer you can ask about
your employer's policies on tuition
reimbursement see if they will help you
with the cost of the program that's
again your employer's policy but part of
UMass Amherst or symptoms
um for more assistance again please
reach out to us at ask us simplywin.net
and answer your questions and get the
process started for you
so at this point I'm going to ask one
more question before we go to questions
and answers which is
if you're interested in this program how
soon would you like to start
and we always say that if something is
going to change your life and your
career for the better always better to
do it sooner than later
so I'm looking at about 50 of the
audience wants to start either in this
cohort starts in January or the one
afterward
and if you're looking further down the
road please do contact us at ask us at
simplyun.net and track will help you
stay in the loop
learn about future cohorts
but with that I'm going to go to
questions and answers I will stop
sharing the screen because you don't
need to stare at that slide
I will
go to some of the questions here
excuse me for a second there we go
um I changed color on this on this
platform so I apologize for being Orange
um
we just have a few questions in the Q a
please if you have additional ones
please put them in the Q a
um so Jan Carlos asks
how do you create databases with
JavaScript CSS or HTML
can you answer some of that for uh
issue
yeah I think it's uh I think the
database is located in an SQL and MySQL
or maybe you might use some different uh
database so JavaScript is basically a
front-end uh scripting language and uh
CSS is basically cascading style sheet
so there are different Technologies and
for databases uh you need to learn about
my SQL SQL
and maybe Oracle databases
depending on the requirement
we have another question uh the only
other one I see right now so if you have
other questions please put them in but
the other question is
what type of experience does someone
need to get a job in UI ux
okay
so uh first of all like to clarify here
that UI and ux are not the same not
completely same but they however overlap
especially if you're going to fifty
percent
they probably expect you to work as a ux
designer also and a UI designer as well
side by side
now coming to the experience the
actually you don't need any experience
it's good to have experience as a as an
internship or if you have some
experience in uh front-end development
or designing modern crafting doing
that's always helpful for you but with
the program I simply done you are going
to do a Capstone project which gives you
a real life scenario examples of the ux
project so once you have a good
portfolio I think the portfolio is more
important here and if you have a good
portfolio you can get a job as a UI
designer or as a ux designer or maybe a
combination of content
okay thank you for that
um one of our attendees missed some of
the opening
um so I will tell you that we will be
sending out an email with a link to this
recording and um but the question that
he has is uh
does UI ux mostly entail design work or
research and marketing or does it vary
from position to position
I would say it varies from position to
position uh depending on at what role
you are entering in the sis ux designer
or a UI designer if you're a UI designer
your major work is related to the
designing work and if you're going as a
ux designer you'll probably be doing a
research or doing the research in
marketing so you might have multiple
roles in in as a ux designer so
uh the job roles vary from industry to
Industry and what kind of an
organization or what kind of a business
process you're getting enrolled in so uh
it totally depends on that
um
take a quick look
what is the cost the cost as we covered
is eight thousand dollars
that's the total cost
and the uh
costs can be financed over time
704 a month
we have a question I'm not sure I
understand the specific question but
what skills do I need to build PSO
systems play with that term
sorry it was oh I I don't really have
experience with working with the PSO
system but probably it's of what a
particular University but to generalize
this question uh whatever systems you
are building with
ux can be applied anywhere so ux is just
not about technology driven ux is about
you can apply this principle in any job
role and what kind of doesn't matter
what kind of product you're building it
so once you learn ux as a skill set you
can apply this to build up your startup
to build up your business or to solve
any real world problems
yeah and I think our whole last couple
of questions uh PSO for wholesale
so
I think basically as you as you said the
skills are transferable across different
Industries and applications
and
um so a great question here how to apply
as a fresher if most of the job
descriptions and listings ask for
experience what will this program
I think you
sort of answered previously but what
specifically this program bring
to enable somebody to get a job as a
fresher
I think that that's very much true so
most of the companies look for
experience and there are multiple ways
especially in the ux and the UI industry
you can get experience you can get
experience by doing freelance projects
doing projects for your friends or just
taking some fictitious project and
building a portfolio and I think that's
a great way to get started as a fresher
and build your portfolio and gain
experience at the same time I think
initially one thing which I tell to my
participants or my students when they
are doing this program with me is that
uh don't focus on what you will get
after doing a particular project focus
on your learning initially and once
you'll put up your your best in a
project as a portfolio building project
you can surely get a job because you
gain lot of experience from that
okay
and that pretty much covers the
questions we have so I'll move on to the
very last
bit of the presentation
here
so we have just one last question uh if
you are interested in Rolling in the
program
do you need
okay
I'm going to ask you to bear
way back in a couple of moments
the poll
and
waiting for me
okay
sorry about that it uh
launch the poll now
it's a quick question if if you're
interested in enrolling in the program
do you need assistance from us or are
you ready
to get started
let's leave this open for a bit
okay
and another 10 seconds
here's the answer
so about two-thirds of you are
interested in getting assistance from us
do contact us at ask us at
simplylearn.net get those questions and
get started and the other uh aspect is
if you're not
quite ready please do contact us as well
in order to um
to keep track make sure that your uh
informed about future cohorts of the
program and get any questions that you
have answered
so with that I want to thank everyone
for being here I'm going to put into the
chat one more time the
contact information
and find it
hold on for just a moment
it's kind of taking a moment
apologize
okay I'm putting this back into the chat
for you
so that it's uh easily accessible
and you can also use the QR code to go
to the page uh the program page on our
website
but do email us at ask us at
simpsonline.net and at this point I want
to thank vishu for being here being so
generous with his time and his expertise
and I want to thank everyone who joined
us in our audience either uh on the
streaming services or on Zoom
um we hope we can welcome you into the
Learning Community with University of
Amherst University of Massachusetts and
Amherst
and thank you again from University and
from Simply learn
that concludes our webinar for today